استقبال وحجاج وتجاره بسيطه جذور بنيت
عليها العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه الممتده
منذ 77 عاما
[تصفيق]
العلاقات التي ابتسمت ببساطه اوليه اتخذت
شكلها الرسمي قبل 32 عاما بعد اتفاق
البلدين على اقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه كامله
وتبادل السفراء وتنظيم اجتماعات على
مستويات سياسيه واقتصاديه وغيرها
[تصفيق]
محطات عده طبعت هذه المرحله كتشكيل لجنه
سعوديه صينيه مشتركه عام 2004 برئاسه وزير
خارجيه البلدين والاتفاق على بدء حوارا
سياسيا منتظمه تبعها الاعلان عن اقامه
علاقات الصداقه الاستراتيجيه عام 2008
[تصفيق]
من محطتها كذلك زيارتان للملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز اولها في عام 99 حين كان اميرا
لمنطقه الرياض اما الثانيها في عام 2014
كوليا للعهد وكانت تاكيد مجددا على
اعتزازه بمستوى العلاقات الثنائيه التي
تشمل مختلف اوجه التعاون المشترك
[تصفيق]
وما بينها زيارات لرؤساء الصينيين للمملكه
ملفاته مره اخرى شملله التشديد على
التعاون والتشاور والتنسيق سعيا لتعزيز
السلم والامن الاقليميا ودوليا
وهنا المواقف ثابته عند ضروره ايجاد تسويه
سياسيه عاجله للمساله السوريه ووحده اليمن
وسيادته
[تصفيق]
وعلى هامشي قمم الدوليه لقاءات لولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان من رئيس الصينيه
احدها في قمه دول مجموعه العشرين
بالارجنتين عام 2018
اعقبها بزياره الى بكين في العام التالي
حرص على تبادل الزيارات رفيعه المستوى غزه
ومجموعه التفاهمات بالمجلات الاقتصاديه
تذهب باتجاه المواكمه بين مبادره الحزام
والطريق ورؤيه 2030 فالسعوديه الشريك
الرئيسي للجمهوريه الشعبيه في المنطقه
مسؤولينا سينين